>> Eric: TOP HEALTH EXPERT
SAYS THAT FOR AMERICANS WILL
PROBABLY BE WEARING FACE MASKS
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
A SCHOLAR SAYS IT "I THINK THAT
WEARING MASKS AND SOME DEGREE OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS SOMETHING
WE WILL BE LIVING WITH,
HOPEFULLY HAPPILY, FOR SEVERAL
YEARS.
DR. SIEGEL, SEVERAL YEARS?
I MEAN, THE SPANISH FLU IN 1918,
THAT PANDEMIC LASTED TWO YEARS.
UCS WEARING A MASK FOR THAT?
>> ACTUALLY I DON’T THINK WE
WILL BE WEARING MASKS FOR THAT
LONG FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS.
WE ARE HOPING TO GET A VACCINE
WHICH WOULD HELP A LOT WITH
COVID-19 AND BRING US HOPEFULLY
UP TO A LEVEL OF HERD IMMUNITY
WHICH, GIVEN HOW CONTAGIOUS THIS
VIRUS IS, IT’S OVER 50%.
BUT THE REAL ISSUE IS, WHAT IS
THE VALUE OF MASS?
I THINK MASKS WORK, I THINK THEY
ARE VALUABLE.
OBVIOUSLY I WEAR ONE AS A
PHYSICIAN BUT I ALSO WEAR ONE IN
PUBLIC.
I THINK IT’S THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING THAT REALLY GIVES US
WHAT WE NEED.
SO IF YOU ARE STANDING -- AND WE
IS 6 FEET BUT IT’S PROBABLY
FURTHER THAN THAT.
YOU CAN’T CATCH THE VIRUS BY
SOMEBODY COUGHING OR SNEEZING
WHO DOESN’T KNOW THEY HAVE IT.
THE MASK PROTECTS YOU FROM A
WEARER WHO IS INFECTED AND
DOESN’T KNOW IT OR IS COUGHING,
BUT WE DON’T ACTUALLY HAVE THE
STUDIES TO PROVE HOW EFFECTIVE
IT IS.
I CALL THEM ASK THE ICING ON THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING KICK.
AND BY THE WAY IF WE ARE MET
WEARING A MASK, IT CAN’T BE
DIRTY.
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE IT, YOU HAVE
TWO -- >> Eric: I WAS GOING TO
SAY, THERE’VE BEEN SOME STUDIES,
IT’S NOT JUST SNEEZING OR
COUGHING, IT’S BREATHING,
SPEAKING, TALKING, SINGING.
THE AEROSOL STATION AEROSOLIZED
THE AREA.
MANY STATES DON’T HAVE STATEWIDE
MANDATE REQUIREMENTS SO WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO THOSE FOLKS WHO STILL
PUSH BACK AGAINST WEARING A
MASK?
>> ERIC, I’M ALL FOR A MASK
AGAIN BUT A MASK PROTECTS THE
OTHER PEOPLE FROM YOU IF YOU
HAPPEN TO HAVE IT.
THE GOVERNMENT MANDATES ARE FINE
BUT PEOPLE SHOULD DO IT OUT OF A
SENSE OF PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
SOCIAL DISTANCING FIRST, MASKS
ARE SECOND.
MASK IS NOT PERFECT BUT IT ADDED
SOMETHING.
YOU COULD HAVE IT AND NOT KNOW
IT.
YOU COULD BE PRESYMPTOMATIC AND
EVERYONE SHOULD BE WEARING THEM
RIGHT NOW.
ESPECIALLY IN HOT SPOTS.
>> TALKING ABOUT HOT SPOTS, YOU
HAVE SCHOOL COMING UP.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT
THAT?
HERE’S GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO.
>> WE OBVIOUSLY WOULD LIKE TO.
AND WE WANT KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS, >>
DOCTOR, WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE TO
PARENTS?
NEW YORK AND NEW YORK CITY IS
DOING REALLY WELL.
I THINK IT NEW YORK ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT REOPENING
SCHOOLS BECAUSE AS WE KNOW THE
DEATH RATE AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE IS
EXTREMELY LOW.
LESS THAN 4% UNDER THE AGE OF 44
SO THE KIDS EVEN IF THEY GET IT
GET VERY MILD CASES AND WE CAN
TEACH OUR KIDS ABOUT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING, ABOUT WEARING MASKS,
ABOUT HYGIENE, AND WASHING THEIR
HANDS AND USING SANITIZER.
THE OTHER ISSUE THOUGH IS
TEACHERS.
NO ONE HAS SAID THIS BEFORE.
AS A DOCTOR, I’M ON THE FRONT
LINES AND I HAVE MY PATIENTS,
WAITERS ARE ON THE FRONT LINE AT